la télé c'est comme le rodéo quand on
tombe de cheval on est mort la mairie
oui oui qui a déclaré thierry ardisson à
propos d animateur de canal+ justin
qu'on se lève pas trop le bras voilà
j'ai traité des petites émotion visible
ans et tu verras ça arrive ça arrive
quand on travail oit
[Applaudissements]
il va
ça arrive quand on se néglige ses co-mis
en hygiène 62%
t
[Applaudissements]
et
m
alors voir l'une est laminée non non pas
du tout pas du tout mais mais c'est à
dire que je danse je mangerai pas sur
toi vraiment tu crois vraiment que tu
étais première des jeunes parce qu'il ya
un sondage twitter et dans sa façon que
tu es un petit peu en galère là sur
cette petite joute verbale
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ton métier pourtant mais ouais
c'est quoi ton métier très exactement
[Musique]